foreign
[Music]
that spread involuntary freedom from
Asia to Afghanistan
comes a film that takes a few pot shots
at the American Military but drops an
absolute nuke on the entertainment
industry I'm not from Hollywood I'm not
going to [__] your mouth and my time is
extremely valuable America F yeah actors
Fu Matt Damon
Team America World Police
Matt Stone and Trey Parker have cranked
out 25 years of South Park but that's
overshadowed some of their most
important work the time they went to the
Oscars we just wanted to be a part of it
and the blackout drunk commentary track
for cannibal the Musical God I'm so
[__] up you guys
but before Book of Mormon cemented their
status as comedy Legends revisit a
forgotten hit that's hilarious at times
now I have seen everything really have
you seen a man eat his own head
no so then you haven't seen everything
and dated in others Hans bricks oh no
but just goes to remind you they've been
doing this forever their dumb cartoon
has outlived both of their biggest
villains Saddam would you let me do my
job please
do you think puppets are funny hope so
cause they're coming to the big screen
in a big way not with a charm and
cuteness of the Muppets but more of a
Thunderbirds or Captain Scarlet Vibe
crash that helicopter no
Great Britain no where even though the
production was insanely complex and
difficult they moved the puppets bad on
purpose for the sake of Comedy
[Music]
thank you
you know what they're right this is way
funnier than trying
meet Team America they're like the cast
of Starship Troopers only slightly less
wooden there's Chris who tried to warn
us about cats before it was too late
rumpus cat but cavity kept feeling up my
leg I tried to leave but Rubble teaser
held me down and I was raped by Mr
Mistoffelees Joe a big white slice of
All-American dumbass I'd love to show
her full moon night on the cornfields
Sarah the empathetic one Gary
and Lisa whose love scene is the
filthiest thing to happen to a doll
since Ryan Gosling auditioned for Barbie
joining them is Gary an actor with
exactly two jokes one actors are dumb my
acting saved the entire world I'll never
act again you cat out acme boy don't
even try 2. puking is funny
[Music]
okay stop it's not funny anymore
thank you
no I'm scratched that it's funny again
no one is safe from their withering
satire except for disaffected
Libertarians like Matt and Trey who are
always right for not caring about
anything from the clueless military
blowing up the world
[Music]
damn I missed him to the activists who
are gay and bad for thinking that should
stop
to the foreign people who look and sound
different from us get it
Muhammad Jihad is it still Brown face if
it's a puppet but regardless of your
tolerance for early 2000s Edge there's
still plenty of jokes that hit hard if
the terrorists take your prisoner you'll
probably want to take your own life here
you'd better have this and just like all
their other work the songs are the best
part everyone has AIDS Freedom isn't
free I'll just be around foreign
[Music]
so return to a tie most funny people
would beg us to forget in a comedy that
mocks the tropes of 80s action movies
yes the ticking crack while having all
the tropes of mid-aut's Comedy ironic
homophobia that is the way ironic racism
and also somehow ironic adult puppetry
Emma gave Helen all the pleasures a
woman could dream of
she had very large bosoms
[Music]
nope sorry not puppets who kill it's
funny but Canadian we're focusing on
America right now let me give that
oatmeal some brown sugar
yeah starring
Tall Tom Cruise would the guy in the
chair Joey Utah
empaths of Glory Chris Pine dude Nukem
The Hunt For Red Oak Timber and bye
crypto
stringsman the not so Secret Service
[Music]
hi you breaking my boss here huh you
breaking my balls hang on this is a
South Park bit uh Randy you're breaking
my boss here you break my bars Randy is
that allowed can I do that
epic voice guy egg is one of the most
nutritious forms of child to eat we got
no food we got no jobs our Pet's heads
are falling off
would you like a tofu flavored KitKat
respect my authority